[Musique]
j'ai une émotion qui me fascine c'est la
peur comment transformer nos peurs en
moteur plutôt qu'en frein pour moi
dépasser ses peurs c'est oser être soi
même être moi même
c'est un peu ce que j'ai essayé de faire
toute ma vie je vais donc vous proposer
trois clés trois clés qui m'ont permises
à moi de vivre mes rêves de gosse dès
mon plus jeune âge j'ai compris de
manière intuitive que pour être heureux
pour être épanoui il fallait que je sois
capable de dépasser mes peurs au
quotidien à l'époque j'avais deux peur
naturelle après la mort l'une d'entre
elles était le vertige pour dépasser
cette peur du vide il a fallu que je
commence par la base à l'âge de 6 ans
j'ai d'abord appris à sauter depuis le
rebord de la piscine
une fois que j'ai bien maîtriser les
techniques j'ai été capable de faire de
jolis sauts je me suis élancé sur le
plongeoir de 1 m puis de 3 mètres puis
2,5 m à 18 ans je sautais de 23 mètres
de haut dans les gorges du verdon
à 20 ans je sautais depuis 4500 mètres
de haut depuis la fenêtre d'un avion en
chute libre
et aujourd'hui c'est un peu comme si je
sautais depuis la lune parce que la
première de mes peurs c'est la prise de
parole en public
et pourtant je suis là ici devant vous
un télex 18 minutes
surtout il faut pas les dépasser je peux
vous promettre que je vais les dépasser
donc comme vous avez pu le lire je suis
un ancien athlète chevet du
snowboardcross
le snowboard cross en gros c'est une
discipline tout bête c'est du snowboard
mais il ya un mot qui vient [ __ ] le
bordel là dedans c'est le cross on est
quatre ou six sur le départ en même
temps ça dépend des des formats de
course
et quoi qu'il arrive il faudra arriver
dans les premiers des huitièmes de
finale jusqu'à la finale et en fait
entre le départ et l'arrivée il ya une
cinquantaine d'obstacles des virages
relevés des bosses des ruptures de pente
comment est ce que je me positionne face
à chacun de ces obstacles
en gros comment est ce que je me
positionne face à l'adversité
est-ce que c'est 50 raison de faire une
petite faute 50 raisons de ne pas être
performant 50 raisons dessus bien le
tracé 50 raison de me blesser 50 raisons
me tuer ou au contraire est-ce que c'est
pas plutôt 50 raison de prendre du
plaisir
cinquante raison de max et l'airé 50
raisons de devenir performant 50 raison
d'avoir une vision 50 raison de
s'inventer un nouveau rêve 50 raison de
vivre son rêve tout simplement
on est ici sur le départ d'exalead
en 2008 je suis sur le départ numéro
blanc numéro 5 j'ai le dossard blanc le
starter dit qu après attention 5
secondes et ça peut s'ouvrir n'importe
quand et donc là je suis dans le
troupeau
je suis ni devant ni derrière donc du
coup ce que je décide de faire c'est de
laisser un peu de marge à mes
adversaires pour ne pas blesser gêné il
faut que j'arrive à emmagasiner de la
vitesse est là j'arrive sur la fan de
place je suis à l'aspiration et petits
pas après petit pas je vais passer de la
5e place à la troisième place
je suis en position de chasseur devant
moi guam watanabe d'américains c'est
l'actuel leader mondial c'est l'homme à
battre c'est ma bête noire et quoi qu'il
arrive
j'ai un objectif est bien c'est de me
faire g watanabe et donc je suis dans
l'action on est à 3000 m d'altitude à
aspen aux états unis et c'est une course
très physique mais en même temps il faut
être fin la difficulté de notre sport
réside dans le fait qu'il faut être
fidèle à sa stratégie tout en étant à
l'écouté de la conjoncture la stratégie
c'est d'être sur la ligne à plus rapide
du début jusqu'à la fin
la conjoncture cédé 5 bourrin qui sont
autour de moi et qui veulent ma peau je
suis donc dans un environnement qui
change constamment
et là je passe petit à petit à la
première place il ya un truc que je vous
ai pas dit c'est que autant j'adore être
un chasseur mais dès que je suis
chasseur chassé pardon je perds mes
moyens et donc les pensées que parasite
commencent à arriver d'autant plus que
je commence à avoir mal aux jambes
et là je serai une tête une petite faute
c'est vraiment pas grand chose dit
pourtant je vais passer de la première à
la cinquième place
mais là je suis dans l'action et je me
dis que quoi qu'il arrive il faut que je
lâche rien je vais pas je vais pas
baisser les bras
j'ai pas encore passé la ligne d'arrivée
je vais continuer à me battre
le maillot jaune il est devant moi et je
vais me le faire quoi qu'il arrive je
reste concentré je respire je respire le
dernier saut 40 mètres de long 8 mètres
de haut mon adversaire va se faire
déséquilibré par le vent
j'ai passé la ligne d'arrivée en premier
merci beaucoup vous savez pourquoi je me
tape la tête je me tape la tête parce
qu'un an avant sur la même course et en
finale j'avais gagné les qualifications
j'ai chuté lourdement sur la tête et je
ressors d'une hémorragie cérébrale
en gros sur cette course j'avais 50
raison d'avoir peur 50 raison de ne pas
y aller
et pourtant j'ai affronté la mort ce
jour là et j'ai gagné mon pari
merci
nous sommes en février 92 je suis avec
mes quatre frères et soeurs devant la
télé c'est des jeux olympiques
d'albertville
j'sais pas si vous en rappeler c'est
immanquable à l'époque et donc il était
8h - de chez nous on a une règle c'est
qu'à 8 heures quand notre mère rentre du
boulot
si on n'a pas mis le couvert on est mort
et xavier ce jour là me dit paulo tu as
une minute trente pour mettre le couvert
et ira aux jeux olympiques et donc du
coup moi j'adore les défis je met le
couvert en moins d'une minute trente
chevaux jeux olympiques lui aussi le
lendemain il me dit paulo 45 secondes et
tu seras médaillé olympique champ mais
ok le truc c'est que j'avais anticipé
son défi parce que je le connais j'ai
beau être jeune et en amont j'avais déjà
rempli la carafe d'eau j'avais
rapprocher le pam la table jaimy les
couverts et découverts sur les assiettes
j'ai mis le couvert en moins de 45
secondes et chiites venus médaillé
olympique et pas lui merci est ce que
vous savez pourquoi il a les boules
encore aujourd'hui parce qu'il n'a
jamais mis le couvert en moins de 45
secondes
c'est ma pensée magique la pensée
magique
c'est mon premier outil c'est ma
première clé la pensée magique c'est
celle qui vous conditionne c'est celle
qui vous porte qui vous permet de
toujours vous rappeler qui vous êtes
petitpas après petits pas je grandis
je me retrouve en finale de mes premiers
championnats du monde juniors je suis 2e
juste avant le dernier saut on arrive
avec beaucoup de vitesse et au lieu d'
amortir le saut tellement heureux d'être
vice-champion du monde junior je mets
une impulsion j'attrape ma planche fait
une figure
j'avais le style c'était comme ça qu'on
parlait à l'époque j'avais trop la
classe
je me rappelle même d'avoir regardé mon
ombre en l'air manque de bol j'ai
réceptionné trop loin je pose les fesses
je passe la ligne d'arrivée troisième
bon troisième c'est pas grave j'ai ma
planche j'attends qu'on m'appelle pour
monter sur le podium et personnes
m'appellent la journaliste vient me voir
il me dit non paulo en fait t'es pas 3e
et 4e
c'était 5 centimètres derrière le
troisième est là pour gros sentiment de
désarroi de d'injustice de colère de
tristesse il y avait tout est en fait
vous savez ce qui s'est passé c'est que
juste avant cette bosse j'étais heureux
j'étais dans la joie mais je n'ai pas
été capable d'identifier cette émotion
de manière assez fine et donc je n'ai
pas été capable de la maîtriser ma joie
s'est transformé en euphorie et
l'euphorie a engendré un comportement
destructeur en gros au lieu de regarder
l'objectif d'être pleinement dans ce que
j'avais à faire pour atteindre mon
résultat
et bah j'ai préféré mais j'ai préféré me
regarder mon nombril en rentrant chez
moi je croise mon cousin nicolas qui
avait 8 ans puisque moi cette philosophe
de la famille et il me dit mais paulo
baisse pas les bras
tu sais très bien que l'échec fait
partie de la construction c'est pas moi
qui vais te l'apprendre et donc en fait
il me cite oscar wilde dans la vie faut
toujours viser la lune car même en cas
d'échec
tu la tva dans les étoiles ok très bien
donc ça veut dire quoi
ben c'est évident paulo
fixe le toit des objectifs extrêmement
haut est temps que dans les
comportements constructif même si tu
n'atteins pas ton objectif même si tu
n'atteins pas la lune tu iras même
peut-être encore plus loin et moi c'est
pas vraiment ce que j'ai compris ce que
j'ai compris c'est pour atteindre la
lune
il faut viser les étoiles donc vise le
plus haut possible et tu auras fait des
choses incroyables
donc en gros mon rêve c'est quoi c'est
d'être snowboarder professionnels et
pour être snowboarder professionnel je
me convaincs qu'il faut que je sois
champion olympique pour atteindre la
lune
il faut viser des étoiles c'est la
pensée motivante qui m'a habité tout au
long de ma carrière sportive qui m'a
attiré tellement souvent
petitpas après petits pas j'arrive en
finale des jeux olympiques à trois
minutes du départ
je vais voir mes adversaires je les
prends dans mes bras et je leur dis
[ __ ] les mecs on est en train de vivre
notre rêve
savourant ce intestins et donc on part
dans la course de départ est lancé
je suis tout à gauche j'suis pas
habituellement un super starter est donc
là je pars je me dis oh mon dieu c'est
la finale et ja morty mal ce premier
saut du coup je perds une vitesse est
très stratégique
je sens l'espagnol jordi funky et 4e
revenir dessus
jordy a toujours des trajectoires
intérieur et moi je me dis ok d'abord tu
va déstabiliser déstabiliser gentil en
l'obligeant à aller à l'extérieur et
ensuite tu te feras les autres manque de
bol je l' ai tellement déstabilisé qu'il
est monté sur ma planche
on est tombés tous les deux
heureusement pour moi je me relève
devant lui et je termine troisième
je termine médaillé olympique cette
médaille va changer beaucoup de choses
pour moi et elle va surtout changer une
chose c'est le regard de la totalité de
mon entourage proche comme lointain les
gens ne me vois plus pareil je passe de
la outsider au seul médaillé olympique
du snowboard français
quatre ans plus tard j'arrive donc sur
ces nouveaux jeux olympiques de
vancouver en 2010 avec un nouveau statut
et avec une nouvelle peur je n'ai pas
été capable d'identifier cette peur qui
était central c'était la peur de perdre
mon âme et mon statut de médaillé
olympique qui revient à la peur de ne
plus exister
je ne les je ne vais pas regarder dans
les yeux je ne vais pas maîtrisé et
c'est comme ça je suis passé de la 3e
place à la 25e place après une énorme
remise en question un gros travail sur
mes faiblesses tant sur le plan physique
que quelques oeufs d'or que technique
pardon je remonte les marches les unes
après les autres
j'arrive en 2014 je fais à nouveau
partie du top 10 mondial et manque de
bol trente quatre jours avant trente
cinq jours avant les jeux olympiques
c'est l'accident
c'est la conjoncture qui vient de
frapper de plein fouet donc je suis dans
l'action tout va bien suite au sein
[Musique]
l'italien vient toucher ma planche
encore une fois sur le sommet de la
bosse et je tombe de trois mètres de
haut sur la tête sur le plat sur la
glace en gros je suis dans l'action je
me dis ou merde pas bon je ferme les
yeux
j'ouvre les yeux et j'entends imbibé
derrière moi j'ai déménagé des tuyaux
partout et le neurochirurgien qui vient
me voir
état des lieux ok triple fracture du
plancher orbital oedème pulmonaire vous
aller cracher du sang pendant trois
semaines vous ne contrôlerez pas vos
yeux pendant un moment et c'est sur tous
vos maux de tête votre concentration
bon bref j'en passe en gros c'était la
merde et donc là je le regarde et puis
je me répète dans ma tête de manière
instinctive pour atteindre la lune il
faut viser les étoiles c'est ma pensée
motivante
et j'ai dit ok très bien docteur est-ce
que j'ai une hémorragie cérébrale
il me dit que non et j'ai fait et très
bien bas soyez bons parce que dans
trente quatre jours il ya les jo
il faut que vous me remettez sur paix
sur pied et donc il part je l'entends
glousser dans le jeu en tant que pousser
dans le dans le couloir mais moi j'ai
une toute petite fenêtre et il faut que
je la saisisse
donc je vais mettre toutes les chances
de mon côté donc c'est lors de
l'élaboration de la stratégie quelles
sont mes forces quelles sont mes
faiblesses mon environnement actuel mon
objectif précis je sais ce que c'est ok
alors je vais prendre pendant dix jours
je vais dormir 18 heures par jour et
ensuite je vais m'entourer des meilleurs
jeux à dacca breton au cers aux
meilleurs centres de rééducation je
connais ces gens j'ai l'habitude de
travailler avec eux mais par contre il
ya une angoisse qui me tétanise et qui
m'habite 116 c est ce que je serai prêt
le jour j
je sais pas pour pour vous tous avez
déjà tous gérés enfin ou en tout cas
organiser des projets à chaque fois on
se pose la question mais est-ce que ce
que je suis en train de faire c'est la
meilleure des solutions à ce que est ce
que c'est ça qu'il faut que je fasse
et en fait vous dites plus tout vous
dites plutôt est ce que je serais
vraiment prêt j'ai un ancien entraîneur
qui est venu me voir et qui me dit paulo
remet le doute à sa place tu as
suffisamment douté durant ta stratégie
tu sais exactement ce que tu dois faire
maintenant soit dans l'instant présent
et savoir si tu seras prêt oui ou non il
posera la question en temps et en heure
la veille de la compétition et donc à
partir du moment où ils disent à mes
épaules à descendre de 10 cm je suis
beaucoup plus serein et je suis dans
l'instant j'avance micro pas après micro
pas quand il faut que je fasse mes
traction fait mais traction quand il
faut que je fasse mes étirements je fais
mes tirs - je les fais bien la veille de
la course
j'arrive devant mon docteur et mon
entraîneur et c'est l'état des lieux
neurologiquement ça passe mais si jamais
tu te blesses tu sais que ça peut être
fatal et donc mon entraîneur me dit pas
question personne ne voulait prendre la
responsabilité que je parte et donc en
fait les écouter c'était encore 50
raison d'avoir peur
si quelqu'un m'avait dit formellement
non tu n'y vas pas je n'y serais pas
allé mais j'étais capable d'être fidèle
à une stratégie tout en étant à l'écouté
de la conjoncture je l'avais déjà
démontré dans le passé et je savais que
j'allais le montrer encore une fois
donc du coup mon pote mon entraîneur me
dit ok mais si tu fais la moindre faute
entre les entraînements et la demi
finale je te sort très bien donc du coup
petitpas après petits pas je suis en
finale je suis contre les cinq meilleurs
mondiaux
pour eux la course commence et moi je
suis assis j'ai plus d'énergie
j'ai la tête qui tourne au bout de ma
vie mais mais ça va quand même on en
finale olympique
allez je suis le plus éloigné d'alina
plus rapide quoi qu'il arrive j'ai
aucune chance d'être devant donc je suis
dans le troupeau
je respecte un minimum de distance entre
mes adversaires et moi surtout je ne
fais rien d'idiot
je suis bien concentré je laisse glisser
ma planche je suis 4e ok vous savez que
dans ma préparation je n'ai pas pu
travailler physiquement sur le plan de
la force ni sur l'endurance ni sur
l'explosivité mais j'avais une vraie
force c'était ma proprioception c'est
une finesse musculaire et donc en fait
c'est ce que j'arrivais à faire entre le
deuxième virage nous sommes dans le
deuxième virage et troisième virage à
chaque run j'ai réussi à redoubler mes
adversaires et là je passe de 4e à 3e et
je me dis oh mon dieu paulo est en train
de revivre turin oh mon dieu c'est
maintenant n'en paulo te laisse pas
déconcentrer
tu as le russe devant toi tu vas te le
faire tu vas faire la première place
avec peer est allé prendre la
trajectoire extérieure souffle souffle
surtout mes toiles aspirations joue à
lennon mais polonais en finale non non
non si vous enlève cette pensée parasite
continu-continu bats toi là je suis dans
les rollers et attention c'est
maintenant
est ce que vous savez ce qui se passe à
ce moment précis je suis en l'air et
c'est la lutte entre le conscient et
l'inconscient le conscient qui dit vas-y
polos t un dingue tu vas te le faire et
à côté ouais mais t'as pas envie de
crever quand même c'est bon tu peut
relancer et donc j'absorbe mal manceau
et je fais une petite faute je me
retrouve de troisième à quatrième et là
je serre les dents joueurs au plus tard
j'en peux plus aller quand même glissé
soient concentrés regarder la position
que j'ai en l'air je suis tout tendues
j'ai plus de jus et il faut que je tombe
sur mes pieds je franchis la ligne et je
me dis oh mon dieu qui reste à gagner et
moi je suis allé plus loin possible
tellement content pour mon pote
vous savez notre sport peut paraître
aléatoire mais finalement il est patient
il est pas si aléatoire que ça en trois
olympiades j'en ai réussi 2 même si la
deuxième fois je suis pas je suis pas
médaille olympique
par contre dans mon travail
d'introspection vous rappeler la pensée
motivante qui m'attire et si souvent
c'était ma résilience
c'était également une pensée limitantes
je me suis rendu compte que deux fois
dans ma vie j'étais à deux doigts de me
battre pour le fin pour le titre de
champion olympique et deux fois dans ma
vie j'ai renoncé avant même d'avoir
essayé pour atteindre la lune il faut
viser les étoiles à trop relativiser vos
objectifs
mais finalement vous accepter l'échec et
en en discutant autour de moi tous les
gens qui ont identifié leurs pensées
motivante et ben ils ont tous dans leurs
pensées motivante
une pensée limitantes donc quelle est la
première de vos pensées motivante qui
vous a amenée jusqu'à aujourd'hui
jusqu'ici et quelle est la pensée
limitantes qui se cache derrière elle
j'ai donc trois clés la première c'est
la pensée magique la pensée magique et
celles qui vous conditionne c'est celle
qui vous porte et qui vous rappellent
qu'ils vous êtes la deuxième clé c'est
là
ans et motivante c'est celle qui vous
tire du plus profond des abysses qui
vous remet en actions qui vous donne de
l'énergie qui vous permet de ne jamais
oublier
ou est-ce que vous allez est en fête et
enfin la troisième de mek les bains
l'instant présent qui vous entre ici et
maintenant qui vous permet de vivre
pleinement votre vie qui vous permet de
ne pas réfléchir à la peur de la peur de
demain vous savez quand j'étais enfant
le monde pour moi était magique
aujourd'hui il est encore plus que
magique je suis père de deux enfants je
m'éclate
vous savez pourquoi parce que je n'ai
jamais renoncé à ma capacité à vivre mes
rêves
hier comme aujourd'hui comme demain
c'est ce qui me définit c'est mon
identité
et vous quels sont vos rêves
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]